en la noche Es cuando ocurre la magia
este grupo de artistas está montando la
estructura que en la mañana sostendrá
las gigantescas cometas de papel de
china que hicieron famoso a sumpango
este pueblo de Guatemala
y como la armazón es en plena noche y
estamos Pues justo en la luna Bajo la
Luna verdad por eso que alcanza un pan
con Nosotros le llamamos la lunada del
barrilete ni vas a dormir por la emoción
Juan Pablo se unió a la tradición desde
sus 12 años pero es la primera vez que
participa en la exhibición con su grupo
ahí nomás por qué hacer barriletes pues
cuentan que al momento de que el papel
china cuando uno no eleva choca con el
viento ese sonido que provoca no le
gusta a los malos espíritus después de
desvelarse toda la noche los artistas
reciben la madrugada y a las 200.000
personas que acoge el evento se arreglan
los últimos detalles artísticos y
empieza la demostración para comunicarse
con los muertos vamos una fiesta de
sincretismo católico que se mezcla con
la tradición indígena de Mesoamérica
las energías de los muertos que que se
han ido
a la hora de nosotros estamos espantando
ahí en Peñas más allá es donde tienen
que pertenecer y no mantener a molestar
a los vivos
esta tradición de de un siglo evolucionó
con la aparición de grupos de artistas
de mujeres los gestos de los expertos
para hacer volar los enormes barriletes
se siguen transmitiendo de manera oral
[Música]
una herencia cultural que sigue poniendo
por lo alto literalmente la cultura maya